hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
on April 22nd 2019 what's going on how
are ya right now you're probably
wondering what is with his tawny sounds
happy and I and you know what you're
like Oh what to the Bruins when
yesterday what happened I don't know all
right because right now I'm watching
life I'm watching the Bruins Toronto
with 1445 to go in the second period hey
come to pro and streaking up the right
side sorry can't yell my daughter's
taking a nap I don't know what happened
with this game was just like Toronto
came out like [ __ ] gangbusters and I
was like well this is finally their year
you know they're just a better goddamn
team but you know what the Bruins came
back with the goal by Brad Marchand
oh no who scored the first one Tori crew
got the first one and then Marchand got
the one right off the faceoff after
Bergy one version where I won one yet
another faceoff so right now it's two to
one obviously the next goal is huge
I feel like whoever scores next is gonna
win this [ __ ] game that's what I
think that's my big bold prediction so I
got the game on in the background this
is like a [ __ ] NBA game where it's
like it's a game of runs like all of a
sudden now now [ __ ] Toronto can't get
the puck I'll talk you know I'll never
understand this game of hockey
you know anyways I want to thank
everybody that came out to the f is for
family panel that we did on say it was
really cool man I felt like the crowd
was really I'd something happened after
season 3 where I think we finally pushed
through to not being underground as much
where people are finally actually
watching the show and yeah I felt really
proud sitting up there with Mike Price
Vince Vaughn and Peter Billingsley the
[ __ ] Mount Rushmore of the show not
kidding it's that take so it takes the
city but we had a bunch
voiceover actors showed up Trevor Duvall
was there Phil Hendry Debi Derryberry
was there imagine there was a couple
others that of course I'm gonna forget
I think Moe Collins was there maybe
Kevin Michael Richardson any hope it was
it was a great time and people said a
bunch of nice things and what I was
loving as much as they were saying oh my
god the third season is your best season
I actually think season four is gonna be
even better
and I'm thinking sometime around season
11 or 12 I think we might I think we
might get nominated for something wow
what are you gonna do so anyway I am
sitting here on pins and needles hoping
my my Boston Bruins are gonna push a
force a Game seven
and if they don't I'm rooting for the
Leafs and I've come to this new this new
place as a sports fan where I just
realized all those years I spent hating
teams and hating great players and then
they go and they retire and I'm like
wait a minute I'm gonna miss this guy
this guy was great I know you root
against him because they were on the
other team but uh
and now feels a lot better if you lose
to a team to be a you-know-what good
good feel good luck to you you know what
the [ __ ] is Boston supposed to win
everything every year I mean how this
run last no I'm just I'm gonna I'm gonna
go into that mode this is all me getting
rid of my ridiculous [ __ ] anger I'll
still have it I'll still have it for my
comedy act God knows I went up last
night and oh Jesus
I went up down the improv here on
Melrose and I went up at the Laugh
Factory down in Long Beach and whoo Oh
stink a roof the new jokes just not just
not working I'm kind of coming out with
this really [ __ ] stupid one
that I just ran by a bunch of jaded guys
and they all told me it was funny and
then like you know women in like anybody
who's like remotely happy as a man they
just saw staring at me like come on Phil
don't you think you're a little bit
better than that all right well I'm you
know you saw that documentary free solo
that's what this podcast is like right
now because I don't have any advertising
or any [ __ ] emails because my stupid
emails aren't loading and then I went on
the internet and God bless this guy in a
second language he was trying to tell me
how to do is I go border border and I
couldn't understand what the [ __ ] he was
saying and then he was on his phone and
I slowed it down and enlarge the things
so I could see what the hell the guy was
talking about and I don't know every
[ __ ] tonight I Google [ __ ] every time
I Google stuff like whatever they're
saying is like okay click on the Apple
go to System Preferences and then click
on [ __ ] I don't know software update
or whatever they say and this [ __ ] it's
just Bam Bam Bam and mine is always like
Bam Bam go [ __ ] yourself it's like I
don't have that I mean I don't know what
I need I got to have like automatic
updates because I feel like everybody's
always like to vote two episodes ahead
of me whatever the hell it is you're
supposed to say so I don't have any
[ __ ] emails
I asked Andrew to send a via text he
responded with sure you know sure is a
very funny word you know it's one of
those words that's like positive and
it's also very passive-aggressive would
you mind doing that sure or sure a lot
of ways a lot of ways to read that the
lovely knee is in the background haven't
been on the podcast in a while you gonna
come on no in a little bit oh yeah you
get over you graces get it there come
the Bruins down the ice a possible two
on one and we [ __ ] it up Scott on a
[ __ ] any score on that sorry
Elba suddenly slowed down oh my god
I just turn on the TV and listen to the
[ __ ] silence
what happened I don't know who anybody
is anymore I got a kid the whole thing
fell apart II just stopped I think he
just flat-out beat him did he tip that
in oh my god
crazy softest hands in the NHL over to
de bras he tips it here today scar three
two one
absolute deafening silence up in Toronto
we even win this game it doesn't mean
[ __ ] because you have to understand as a
leaf fan okay provided you didn't win
today all right you know that even if
you guys beat us your team is gonna
torture you it's not gonna be easy it's
like the other day when you had his
[ __ ] beat and then you let up that
late goal so you still had to be like
[ __ ] all the games are running together
for me I don't know I just know you
totally dominated us in our own building
in Game five and I was just like well
maybe this is finally the year and the
first ten minutes of this game I was
just like they're just the better team I
feel like we're going six you know five
against six out there [ __ ] Bruins I
love this team I swear to god I know the
Celtics won four games in a row which is
[ __ ] awesome I got to get on that
bandwagon I just haven't I just don't
have the time but I really I really am a
hockey fan over basketball I just AM out
Jesus and I stick to the [ __ ] taint
that'll be a penalty right that'll be a
Pennell Jesus that's dangerous oh you
hate to see that good he got his knees
out of the way anyway plowing ahead here
so I'm getting ready to leave to go over
to Iceland middle part of this week and
a knee I want to talk to you about my
packing huh she's already given me [ __ ]
she doesn't get it man she's going to
Iceland but I'm starting in Iceland
she's gonna leave after that and then
I'm going on this I do you know where
this [ __ ] toilet takes me I know I
end up in Israel
you know Oh do I get some opening jokes
over there for them all right wait a
second
let's see bill burr dot-com [ __ ]
funny is that I don't you know where I'm
going
shows I'm going to Copenhagen oh I
always had a good time I take a
Copenhagen I think of that Conti [ __ ]
taxi driver I had alright this is what I
got I'm in Reykjavik Rick javac Iceland
on the 29th I'm in köppen Copenhagen on
the 30th both of those shows are sold
out a second show in Copenhagen is sold
out then I'm in Stockholm Sweden [ __ ]
I've been there forever triumphant
return May 1st and that sold out then I
have two shows in Helsinki on May 2nd
the first show sold out the second one
is not Oslo Norway the spectrum tickets
still available then I'm in Amsterdam
Netherlands that sold out and then I
have a day off and I'm so [ __ ]
tempted to go to Spain and go to that
MotoGP race I just I just not going to
have that's the old me would have done
that and then I'll go here for five
minutes and then I go there for five
minutes or I could spend two days in
Israel you know oh my god do you know
what the name of the place I'm playing
in [ __ ] Israel is Nia you know what
the name of the place I'm playing in
Israel is how great is this I'm playing
the [ __ ] group arena not to be
confused with the Oh Eve a funny bone
what's the matter Shalom oh yes what I
mean I'm saying why did you get all like
that was like some anti-semitic [ __ ]
yeah I said that's great
we don't want to play a cousin Vinny's
[ __ ] arena and Israel slow-mo
Jesus way to take a fun travelling
moment and turn it into a hashtag on
Twitter he sounded excited but was he
really anti-semitic when we return
another white person in their 20s tries
to destroy somebody else on [ __ ]
social media I've been having so much
fun [ __ ] trash and all those [ __ ]
[ __ ] young people out there just
trying to ruin people's lives for their
goddamn cause they're [ __ ] lunatics
[ __ ] lunatics and like as I've said
somebody takes that dick out at work
obviously you gotta say something but
this [ __ ] ticky-tack [ __ ] and you're
gonna sit that you know and try to twist
it around like [ __ ] around like you're
[ __ ] Fox News at CNN it makes
somebody look like an [ __ ] just
because you don't like that political
opinion is it's it's [ __ ] beyond me
anyways I'll be at the [ __ ] group
arena that is [ __ ] awesome
I should double up and go do one in
Palestine you know a little surf and
turf over there get both sides of the
story if you will [ __ ] he's walking it
in Jesus clearing the zone well let's be
icing
don't ask dougie Hamilton you don't know
poor bastard
I like dougie Hamilton by the way I
don't know why I said that but he
[ __ ] I don't what happened he it was
the other night I was watching the
Cape's game it didn't matter cause I got
the [ __ ] kicked out of him but he like
pointed like he called icing and the ref
didn't know vetch can came in and took
the puck passed it to his buddy there
right there Fred bing-bang-boom
by the way I didn't know Calgary are the
best record in the East I mean the West
I would have never would have been
exciting but then they [ __ ] [ __ ] the
bed just like Tampa Pittsburgh is out
I miss it minutes it is [ __ ] wide
open here I got to tell you right now if
these Washington Capitals can get by the
Hurricanes Carolina they got a really
good shot they got as good a shot as
anybody to go out there win the Cup and
that would be a repeat for the first
time since the [ __ ] Detroit Red Wings
is that right the first time since 97
ninety-eight I think that we're already
the Penguins doing maybe the Penguins
didn't I think they did it a few years
ago this will be the all ha ha to Chi
just Snagit it out of the [ __ ] air
via come on on the podcast and talk
about your packing verses my packing
yeah at what point did you stop giving a
[ __ ] about the podcast or is it me you
used to always be like I love going on
the podcast and all of a sudden we have
a kid and you get other priorities since
when does our kid come before the
podcast Nia I'm asking you I love this
commercial with this guy's in like a
racing suit like a fire retardant suit
and he's sitting there going I love my
job and he's all excited because he's
will driving a [ __ ] Honda Civic
really does that get you [ __ ] balls
in an uproar there guys trust like a
race car driver and he's excited to
drive a [ __ ] sophomore in college
chick car if you got money right ok and
then after after Israel the next show I
have is the Wilbur theater in Boston
Massachusetts for the Travis Roy
foundation and then after that I'm doing
September 6 the Cosmopolitan Hotel in
Las Vegas and I have to tell you people
over the summer I will be putting my act
together in local comedy clubs and I'll
try to be giving you the heads up as I
do that over the summer here in Los
Angles a-- all right hey let's read
let's read something that i actually
just found in an email that I could
actually read oh that ain't it that's
notes for season five if we get it
that's how far ahead I am notes on
season five four f is for family this
guy from Australia sent me an email and
let's see what we got here oh and I
somehow [ __ ] deleted ice it's so
[ __ ] annoying man there it is this
[ __ ] guy sent me something said g'day
Billy red nuts love your podcast mate
you crack me up I'm also an older
gentleman who has a small child close to
your daughter's age
so I'd love to hear how she's developing
as my lad is doing the same thing it's
great I hope this is where you get your
emails for the podcast anywho probably
hasn't made news over your way but here
in Australia there's been considerable
problems with militant vegans invading
private farms they're really pissing
people off what has happened to the left
man these they're going [ __ ] crazy I
kind of like him you know
so they got militant vegans Jesus how
much is Australia changed you know they
used to have a crazy guy wrastlin
alligators down there now all of a
sudden they got people [ __ ] going
nuts about kumquats anyways it really
pissing people off a friend came to me
the other day and said how do you know
if someone's a vegan I said I don't know
he said don't worry they'll [ __ ] tell
you ha ha it cracked me up keep it up me
you should head down to Adelaide South
Australia sometime get stuffed your mug
the [ __ ] just gets stuffed me can only
imagine that some sort of [ __ ] take a
dick in your ass I got to tell you right
now I'm watching this [ __ ] game and
what the [ __ ] Bruins are doing right
now if these Maple Leafs of Toronto
don't wake up this [ __ ] game it's
it's over with 6 minutes left in the
second period I said it before the next
goal is gonna win although the way
hockey is I'd say the next goal we go up
4 to 1 I will be feeling good but if
Austin Matthews gets another one here
how [ __ ] great is that guy they
already showed him the beginning the
game they showed him skating slow motion
like when they had the Maple Leafs and
emblem on the ice and he that that 34
Jersey is already ironic iconic I'm
looking at that thing like this guy's
he's gonna be a Hall of Famer I mean
that's not too hard to guess you know
considering he scored four goals in his
first [ __ ] game
Bruins just down the Maple Leafs end the
entire second period at least the part
that I've been looking at all right so
militant vegans near militant vegans are
going [ __ ] nuts over there in
Australia I guess they're marching onto
farms here's the thing about militant
vegans all right you might think they're
[ __ ] but I gotta be honest with you
they're right the way we treat animals
hey I'm all for killing them and eating
them but this [ __ ] like you ever see
what they do to chickens and stuff they
they shoot steroids into their [ __ ]
chicken breasts and they can't even walk
they're tipping over they clip off the
front of their beaks the [ __ ] that we do
to animals is [ __ ] horrible and I
gotta be honest with you this whole
[ __ ] thing is we do it you know so
human beings don't suffer you know I
don't know about that I think at this
point they're just doing it for money I
think enough animals have suffered so I
actually agree with these militant
vegans as far as like how they they view
what we do to animals but I stopped
short of just marching on to somebody's
property and scaring the [ __ ] out of
families and stuff but the problem
though is when you do [ __ ] like that is
everybody just says you're an [ __ ]
but no one was listening to him before
so what are they supposed to do
I'm calling this right now militant
vegans are going to invade our farm and
their love of animals will make them
approach an animal they should not
approach and somebody's going to get
hurt on the vegan side that's that's my
prediction Nia what do you say about
that that's it can you Cheney just come
I don't have any [ __ ] emails I don't
have any advertising can you [ __ ]
pick up a microphone and help me out for
a couple of minutes Jesus Christ you
know what's funny about you the level
that you stress when we go to the
airport okay try to be prepared okay
it's just gonna be the energy or you're
gonna come in and have a little fun yeah
in the middle of my thing so I was kind
of focused on that but uh I'm pack I'm
bringing a backpack you know and a
little carry-on okay for this trip and
I'm just letting you know I'm packing
one shirt and one pair of pants from my
entire tour and then I'll have I'll have
a [ __ ] is this guy a bookie track
suit and for my flights and then I'll
just have some walking around town
clothes and then a bunch of underwear
and socks that's how it sounded tuck
where your comedy instincts you're
supposed to go against it like you did
last night we like we're going to be
going out to dinner all right Andrew
edit all of this out all right I don't
not gonna edit this [ __ ] out I don't
give a [ __ ] what no it really isn't
really gonna bother you if I with the
same shirt every night at all you know
what it is near what when you're going
country to country to country which I
will be doing after we have a little few
days there in Iceland it's like your
stuff just becomes a burden yeah so you
just want to like you know Jim Morrison
wear the same [ __ ] brown leather
pants his entire tour look at that guy
everybody loved him he's not dead cause
of his pants are you comparing Mike
traveling yes the way I travel if it was
good enough for Jim Morrison it's good
enough for me right I talked to Steven
Adler and I said dude you going on a
one-world tour what are you doing goes
easy goes one pair of pants two shirts
yeah sounds disgusting well you're gonna
you somebody's gonna give you a shirt
while you're out there if you're a rock
star
right so that's what you're going for so
look if you're a regular guy like me
when you
let's open hanging oh this is how that's
what you're waiting for no this is how
it works you're pretty stylish so maybe
they can help you I don't know
first of all any European gives me a
shirt it's not going to fit because they
wear like child sizes over there yeah
yeah there's this Slim Whitman over
there no here's the deal as far as a
rock star
you're gonna bang a chicken then they're
gonna give you stuff that's how it works
when you're a rock star he's just a
regular guy like me if you bang somebody
you lose a shirt that's how it worked
when I was a single man okay I'm not
saying now Nia I'm not saying we're
gonna go the [ __ ] arena there and try
to hook I bet you do well I'm gonna go
there I'll get the lay of the land I'll
go to the weeping wall is that what they
call it the crying is that right mm-hmm
I don't know I don't I don't I I'm not
into any of that stuff so I'm gonna like
respectfully stay away from those things
I'm gonna go over there see if they got
a McDonald's get myself a quarter
pounder with cheese no I'm actually
really looking forward to it because you
know historically speaking Jewish people
are some of the funniest people on the
planet you know if you go through show
business remember that Adam Sandler song
there huh all three stooges the Hanukkah
song I know that song yeah I'm just
saying he made all these [ __ ] funny
people yeah don't know why this is so
hard
Mia what happened to our chemistry I
don't know
all right at the height of you loving me
scale of one to ten where was it at what
do you mean at the height of me lemon
yeah we're supposed to mean
well I know you never got to ten dip
down ya know where you end okay I know
you still love me but it's full where's
the like though the like is what shifts
in a marriage that's yeah on one to ten
no that's good I'll take a seven and a
half I've been pretty good about not uh
yelling right I'm a good boy can you pat
me on the
oh thank you you on the other hand
leaving the damn door open why we get
the [ __ ] heat on yeah you got the
door open you like I'm going back out it
was like once again I expressed
something and there's just oh my god you
taking that hit from Chora Jesus he went
up high there that guy just [ __ ]
helmet almost came off yeah a secretary
from the he scored the goal for the boy
he didn't score there wasn't wrong guy
there was a guy from the King's Own
Muzzin all right Nia this has been
incredible you know I know you're
distracted I'm sorry I'm distracted cuz
I am trying to like get my stuff
together here is that a green bag I
would say that's lime green if you're
bringing neon green you're bringing the
80s back it's my carry-on so I'm trying
to get it together see what's happening
I downloaded that album as Bismark yeah
I downloaded that album where they took
that sample from it's such a killer
album the only reason why I know about
is because I'm reading the The Beastie
Boys book that book you did you know
what's really cool in the middle out of
nowhere not in the middle towards the
end it's Chuck chef Roy Choi yeah he's
in there because he's a Beastie Boy fan
he got to know them and he actually
gives you some recipes really yeah in
the middle of an autobiography how great
is it all right so here's an album you
got a download
you got a download the [ __ ] is this
guy's name Eugene McDaniels headless
heroes of the Apocalypse you got you
gotta check that out the supermarket
blues might be my favorite [ __ ] song
on there drums are awesome well he's not
kidding around no this is a very I
believe why people would say militant
rather than he
a african-american man expressing his
displeasure with white people we say
he's militant which sounds borderline
military which white people do support
unless it's a black only sort of
movement as far as I could tell me
minute 22 to go in the second period
near your Boston Bruins are up three
games to one oh my god he missed Jesus
Christ nice Toronto may believe that is
the Toronto made police this is an
original six playoff series is what
you're looking at here that was great
okay enjoy your packing you know it
sucks about traveling with your wife is
no matter how light you pack you still
got to go downstairs to that [ __ ]
baggage claim it's the purple one the
purple one with the hankie on it it's
always like piled on top of three others
you [ __ ] up your lumbar now the Maple
Leafs are racing down the ice look at
this [ __ ] these are the maple leaf she
saw in the first 12 minutes of the game
but here come yet Boston Bruins dumping
a little dumpen chase here we just
content to go in up three two one
I hope which cassadee gets on the rest
why the [ __ ] you're trying to make me
have to put my house on the market
that's what I would say is a head coach
in any sport I would always bring up the
fact that if they lose I'm gonna have to
sell my house and go home and tell my
children that we're moving away from
their friends all right
or you [ __ ] [ __ ] could go out
here and scores of goddamn calls for me
Nia what do you think about militant
vegans in Australia yeah they're down
there shaking a head of [ __ ] lettuce
at people yelling about how much
proteins in iceberg lettuce versus uh
chicken or something I have to be honest
any time I have eaten just vegetarian
you feel great you feel light and all of
that [ __ ]
but there's definitely man you eat a
[ __ ] steak and cheese you need a nap
speaking of which Nia I said speaking of
which steak and cheese
I know Nia's been [ __ ] killing it at
the gym and on her diet
it's amazing and you know what she told
me really warmed my heart she told me
you know why I'm losing this weight I
said why she said I'm doing it for you
because what you think about me is my
entire self esteem and I was just like
that is the most beautiful finish trying
to get it back in the pockets that's the
most beautiful thing anybody has ever
said to me and then she told me you know
what I really think these feminists are
out of line one of the worst things that
ever happened to women was we left the
kitchen it's just unbelievable you
already threw me under the bus at Conan
alright what so I'm not gonna take any
more [ __ ] slander out of you thank you
very much time out yonder is a big word
slander is abusing and 'red my name Wow
because you went on Conan and threw me
under the bus no slander is affect go
and I say something that isn't true stop
acting like you know things you don't
know anything
I know it's slandering you guess it
everything and you threw me under the
bus
and I'm sick of it well wait a minute
wait a minute what did I throw you under
the bus or was it slander it's both it
was not bus throwing it was not you said
white people of the Middle Ages I'm not
I'm not into it first of all it was made
in jest okay right of all you know ya
know it wasn't meant for the public to
hear actin it I tell you something most
people thought it was funny
well I got dragged what'd you get you
got 18 [ __ ] Instagram like I got
people you know making up fake burner
accounts trying to troll me and all that
kind of stuff
do you realize house together what
[ __ ] I'm still not gonna watch Game
of Thrones Oh
give a [ __ ]
I don't care about white people the
Middle Ages or white people with fake
accounts you and your incense dragons
and all that [ __ ] that you like y'all
can keep that and listen there's plenty
of black people who like Game of Thrones
so why don't you go hang out with them
but this black person will be over here
Amy what good what different what what's
going to do with Game of Thrones you can
send that [ __ ] straight to Blockbuster
[Laughter]
we brought back to the buy guys yeah
that's our news that's our new saying
bill came up with it oh yeah of course
and we were watching some trailer -
something some movie and I didn't like
it Oh funny yeah yeah you can take that
[ __ ] straight to Blockbuster cuz ain't
watching and then now died now what
that's become is if somebody's just
suggesting ain't we should go to brunch
there's a new place down the street what
do you think about that you take that
[ __ ] straight to watching it I ain't
doing it that's it
all right let me get back to what I'm
doing here okay Amy it just for the
record you know just so I can throw
myself under the bus and be there - I
don't care about black people in
superhero movies anything you don't want
to watch them I got to be more honest or
white people in superhero movies I don't
like so we're a movie you know like
superhero movies I get it okay
you're a nerd but you're really is
superhero and for some reason some
people don't realize how [ __ ]
shredded you are underneath these dumb
sweater and your glasses all right it's
so [ __ ] stupid
no I don't mind the comic books when I
was a kid but this whole [ __ ] thing
like I don't like how nerds go there and
they look at these people and just peak
human slash whatever whatever else they
are [ __ ] alien mm-hmm
tradition okay and they actually have
the balls to sit there and say that they
can relate you clearly haven't watched
any because you don't understand the
whole like how the story goes for those
what do you mean I haven't watched any
it's like they're all like Al Gore
is for stuff going on in like actual
life and like you know human condition
man that saipin here it's not just yeah
it's not that deep it's not that deep I
see it when I watch it no when I watch
I'm saying I didn't need you explain
that to me
well I know and I don't see a Pixar
movie I know Ice Age is about global
warming okay but you mean I'm just
saying though you're acting like you
don't know cuz you're you're very you're
like very dismissive of the people who
like the the superhero stuff yet don't
you understand that my business formula
is attacking popular [ __ ] all right huh
oh you don't think it's working all
right
I've [ __ ] on Star Wars since day one
which they keep taking new ones and
they're doing better and better not
since day one I liked it when I was a
kid all right well I guess she's gone
again see that look see how that just
worked there all right let's get back to
slandering my wife what are your hobbies
flying helicopters playing drums
slandering my wife here's something else
in the ascent and she said it
specifically about white people in North
Carolina she was like out of all the
dumb southerners that are out there
white people in North Carolina she never
said then sorry I'm typing in my
password here all right it's three to
one in this one period left okay and I
don't think there's anybody relaxed
right now on either side of this [ __ ]
red line all right
I'll tell ya when you got someone in the
caliber Austin Mathews and whatever
Tavarez his first name is and I'll tell
you Anderson is no slouch don't let this
score take away from all these kids been
playing for these first five games of
this series I'll tell you right now the
Bruins I mean I know they're happy to be
up to two girls here but they still got
their work cut out for by the way I
didn't see it then anybody see the
[ __ ] rough and rowdy in West Virginia
how about a [ __ ] round of applause
for West Virginia everybody's always
[ __ ] on him okay but no
one ever talks about how [ __ ]
entertaining they are you're never gonna
see a group of people I mean the level
that they threw them said just the
highlights from those fights do you see
that [ __ ] guy he was getting [ __ ]
lit up by the other dude he just ducked
down like marShon back in the day when
he would tip somebody over he [ __ ]
went down pick this guy up and just body
slammed him it became like an MMA event
and I have a I actually retweeted the
the the clip from Dan Katz sent it over
or tweeted it out how would the [ __ ]
he's supposed to say rough and rowdy
I'll tell you right now that rough and
rowdy the more rough and rowdy the city
they go to the more rough and rowdy it
becomes I miss going to those [ __ ]
events I want to [ __ ] the next one
that comes out if I'm not [ __ ] I'm
always working I got to stay home one
night with a bunch of other comics that
we're just off that night and I want to
watch that [ __ ] maybe I'll just tape
it why don't I do that I don't know bill
there's a lot of Technology out there
Jesus Christ do I need some [ __ ]
reeds at this point all right here we go
oh my god I thought I had a new
advertiser I thought there was a new
website called my foreskin it's actually
an email says my wife is disgusted by my
foreskin that is the dumbest [ __ ] ever
it's like she will get [ __ ] had it
when you met her it's like you grew on
Jesus Christ were you coming down the
aisle and she's just like why am i
marrying this guy with an ugly dick
isn't that ridiculous how they [ __ ]
they just mutilate you the second you
come out and women finally hey ton
mutilated man disgusting can you imagine
that in yeah you know what I find your
[ __ ] disgusting sorry I'm just trying to
get her back in here all right let's do
some reads here oh look who's here
everybody old zip hiring used to be had
multiple job
site stacks of resumes a confusing
review process why do I have to take off
my shirt but but today hiring can be
easy and you only have to get you only
have to go to one place to get it done
zip protip calm / verb simple crude
ascends your job sends your job to over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiters scans thousands of you mean
emails thousands sorry thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience invites them to apply for
your job to your job as applications
come in zip analyzes each one and spots
likes the top candidates so you can so
you never match so you never miss a
great match help me out here now and
right now my listeners can get all zip
for free at this exclusive website zip
recruit calm / / that zip recruit calm /
burn spell it out zi p re crui ter
dot-com / / zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire simply safe ten years ago
getting home security stunk with Delhi
it was a soliloquy
if felt like companies went out of their
way to make your life miserable with
long contracts you never knew what you'd
get you'd pay and they made you rewire
your whole whole home this was normal
then simply safe comes along and totally
transforms home security they did
everything right
they built a better system and they
treat you right simply say stands up to
the unexpected from burglars to
blizzards to blackouts blizzards what is
this safety when there's a blizzard up
does it keep you jewelry warmer must
have an internal heater blackouts Neah
many ways all those little swim goggles
for you-know-who that I mentioned what a
good swimmer my daughter is already she
doesn't even use flow
anymore she's just on that little that
long little worm float tube thing
whatever they got that noodle crushing
it simply safe as 24/7 professional
monitoring and police dispatch
everything to keep your home safe it's a
PC Mag readers choice and a wire cutter
top pick and at one seen it editors
choice twice and simply safe makes your
life easy there's no contract no hidden
fees and no rewiring your home you
already said that three million people
are protected by simply safe already and
not one of them is locked into a
contract
check out simply safe for yourself is it
simply safe bird calm its s impl eye
safe bur dot-com and you'll get free
shipping and free returns plus a 60 day
money back trial what else do we got
it's the last one for the love of [ __ ]
Christ amps calm always they had minor
first they are last to leave here we go
stamps calm no one really has time to go
to the post office you're busy who's got
time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages it's
a real hassle man that's why you need
stamps calm one of the most popular
time-saving tool tools for small
businesses stamps calm eliminates trips
to the post office and saves you money
with discounts that you can't even get
at the post office simply safe uses your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you send your
mail once your mail is ready you just
hand it to your mail carry carrier drop
it in a mailbox it's that simple stamps
comb is that no brainer saves you money
time and money so sorry is a no-brainer
saving you time and money it's no wonder
over 700,000 small businesses are to use
stamps calm right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage in a digital
scale without any long-term contracts
just go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bird that stamps.com enter
per alright how much should we up to
we're up to 42 minutes here near we're
in the break
between the second and third period the
Bruins are up three games to one and I
think I owe it to my listeners to
podcast right through the end of this
game if they give a [ __ ] right by the
way congratulations to the second batch
of stand-up comics that went up on our
premium blend style show for Comedy
Central
my good buddy Josh Adam Maya's closed
out the second one and absolutely
murdered so many people I had [ __ ]
monster assets during this during the
taping and they made all things comedy
look really good and Comedy Central was
psyched and hopefully we'll get to do it
some more and I loved the whole process
getting to meet all these young comics
up-and-coming getting to know who's the
funny people and whatnot and I don't
know it was I think I think we got a
home run there so anyways let's get to
some of the emails here for the week and
then we'll watch the Bruins game
together shall we
although I imagine a bunch of people in
Toronto will be [ __ ] turning this off
if it stays to say or if they have a
miraculous comeback here's the deal I'm
gonna do it until [ __ ] the end of
regulation I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm not
gonna keep going if you don't want these
[ __ ] triple overtime games all right
okay emails Kate Smith dear Billy boo
boo Bird check out this video about the
god Bless America controversy classic
case of generations not understanding
each other love you and love the podcast
all right let's check this out god bless
america
hey why is it well you know every time
Flyers are cutting ties no do you know
what's hilarious
I got a timeout that thing they they
covered the thing that they just covered
Kate Smith's statue up with made her
look like she was the next level she
looks it looks like she's wearing a Klan
hood except it's all black like this you
know the Grand Wizard of Klan guys you
know I think he has a couple extra
patches it's kind of like this Cub
Scouts except with a lot more hatred are
you kidding me what is the evidence she
rose to fame in 1938 when Jewish
composer Irving Berlin rewrote god Bless
America specifically for Smith and as a
peacetime protest of Adolf Hitler
because of Smith's rendition god Bless
America became this country's wait a
[ __ ] minute what is this [ __ ] there's
new evidence
kay Smith
racist evidence I mean what did she send
a text message somebody just found okay
wait a second wasn't everybody racist
back then cuz even if you were liberal
what you thought was nowhere near where
the [ __ ] we are now this is so dumb this
is really bad man you can't come up and
go back when somebody's not alive to
defend themselves all right how come
nobody back then said she was racist is
that because everyone was racist back
then and if they were wasn't she just a
victim of her time with the information
that was available I mean there was time
people walked around they thought
slavery yeah that makes sense to me
because that's what people did it says
you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] we're doing right
now do you think you're gonna [ __ ]
get 280 and look back on [ __ ] you did in
your 20s you're like oh my god I can't
believe we used to do this [ __ ] or said
that or eight that I thought this
alright who says one fan can't make a
difference it was one fan who contacted
the Yankees about Kate Smith's racist
singing background that caused them to
remove the god Bless America from the
seventh-inning stretch which caused
Stefan Bondi of the New York Daily News
to write about it which also caused the
Philadelphia Flyers to not only remove
her song but cover up the statue outside
the extent Xfinity live as well I spoke
with Bondi before his Inside Edition
experienced appearance he said I
obviously didn't expect the reaction
that it got well what did you think was
going to happen
says Bondi but I think it's a sign of
the times and a good sign that the
Flyers also reacted the way they did
meanwhile the Redskins are still called
the Redskins none of this [ __ ] makes
sense so as Kate Smith really a racist
or struggling artist trying to get work
nobody knows and I think that's still
part of the investigation Bondi said
well then what the [ __ ] how are you
going to investigate that after she's
dead and everybody else who was part of
the class was dead how are you going to
investigate this you just slandered
somebody's [ __ ] name speaking of
slander there's not been much as to who
Kate Smith is as a person
there hasn't been any stories to suggest
that she did anything racially
insensitive in her private life but
there are these songs Bondi said she was
born in the South raised during the time
of Jim Crow laws yet this isn't her
fault it was a racist time they were did
these were different times and some of
the things she said would have been
racist back then you still get to pick
what wait a second and some of the
things she said would have been racist
back then you still get to pick some of
the songs she's saying this is these
[ __ ] people who is this Brody person
let me can we investigate your life to
this level
you never said anything you didn't do
anything you didn't laugh at somebody
can we destroy your [ __ ] life now put
a [ __ ] sack over your head what about
the fact that these songs were recorded
so long ago when the times were so
different obviously says I like how they
talk to this bondi person like this
person some sort of expert I'm sure was
interpreted differently in 1939 but it's
not 1939 yeah but it was when she did it
this [ __ ] back then dude that's like
when they come up with a new law you
can't prosecute somebody for doing
something yesterday that today is now
illegal but it's not 1939 and that song
is being played to all sorts of people
of race and color and created Yankee
Stadium in 2019 yeah god Bless America
not the racist song I don't get this I
don't get this at all I don't get I
don't get in this and then they try to
get the Flyers in trouble you can also
add the Flyers to that list as people
not playing this song but one has to
wonder what would they have done if it
if it were game 7 of the Stanley Cup
Finals and they played the song before
the last three wins this is all this is
this whole [ __ ] error is just trying
to get people in trouble I think when
you do something like that to somebody
they should immediately they should
immediately investigate your life if
you're gonna take somebody down we're
not gonna investigate your life to see
if we need to take you down too and you
know what watch everybody shut the [ __ ]
up because we're all guilty of something
myself included give me a [ __ ] break
we've all done [ __ ] we've all said [ __ ]
we mean part of life is growing as a
person I bet if you asked her at the end
of her life what do you think about
those songs I bet she did we have a
different opinion than when the [ __ ] she
sung them it didn't even say how old she
was when she sang the song it's so
[ __ ] stupid I think that's ridiculous
I think it's ridiculous and it's this
[ __ ] thing that white people who live
now do
they try to act like they're trying to
be brave and sensitive and what they're
really doing is they're using somebody
else to [ __ ] show how awesome they
are or something it's I think it's all
self-serving I don't know and I'm also
assuming this person's white which I
probably shouldn't but I don't know I
just know all of my black friends when I
brought up that Contras about John Wayne
they all just laughed like who gives a
[ __ ] about a dead white guy we're
dealing with the white people that are
still alive
all right Ukraine president dear bill
president day 0:02 virus point-blank
50:58 so dear bill president day there's
is hope for the world oh thank god hey
guys how about some more positive [ __ ]
too by the way
becoming a comedic personality from the
Ukraine just beat the incumbent in a
landslide to become president what is
that a good thing I don't think I want
to [ __ ] clown run in my country when
are you running and what's your slogan
gonna be what will you do about the
Middle East who will be your vice
alright i'll answer these questions this
is what I do about the Middle East
Toronto just scored uh-oh and now ladies
and gentlemen we have a [ __ ] game
here was that Austin Matthews again he's
[ __ ] awesome oh my god they keep
getting us with that [ __ ] let me
watch this replay
oh my how he came he uh touka went from
right to left and then he shot it over
his right shoulder like the [ __ ]
sniper that he is top shelf and look at
the look on his face look at him
Jesus Christ alright growing's ah [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me I was relaxed and now I am
NOT Toronto wins the faceoff in the
Bruins zone all right just relax don't
be a bunch of puck Jason jackasses and
just [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh boy oh boy oh they
got the puck oh Jesus
they go d-daddy all right
I can't watch this [ __ ] there you go
take the [ __ ] body something anyways
I remember what the [ __ ] I was talking
about oh how I would solve the Middle
East all right first of all I would
convert this country to solar power
I would enact that guy from Tesla's
plans for that solar [ __ ] on the roads
and then his his is I would just convert
all of this to solar alright and I would
give you know all of the money to the
oil companies and just say listen you're
gonna be out of this [ __ ] business
and we're gonna help you go over to this
other business alright so you're still
getting all the money from the energy
you [ __ ] and then what's gonna happen
is there's gonna be no [ __ ] money in
the Middle East and then they won't have
any money to finance the terrorism and
then we're gonna get the [ __ ] out of
there and leave them alone okay that's
what we're gonna do and then they can
[ __ ] live their lives and we're gonna
live our lives and then I don't know if
I would have the power to do this but I
would go and I would advocate of Israel
and all the Palestinians out of
Palestine [ __ ] where would I put them I
gotta give them beachfront property
because it seems to be really important
to those people
I give them all timeshares in Florida
Boca Raton we get Acapulco going again
you know now there's no there's no salt
in the Middle East but I would get us
the [ __ ] out of that hornet's nest is
what I would do and I would leave those
people alone because it's their
country's and they should be able to
figure out what the [ __ ] goes on in
their countries and I'd convert us to
solar power that's what I was doing my
vice president would be somebody way
smarter than me and I would have him
sound out all the big words in my
speeches before I went on TV so you guys
all thought I was smart and you kept the
faith all right then I would go to
Blackwater and I would I would carve out
a deal with them um well we would take
the banking system back all right and we
just whack a couple of top bankers I
don't think we'd have to do that we
would just walk in and take them over
take over the banks you're too big to
fail is that what you think dizzy all
right there Fred and they would all go
to [ __ ] jail okay and then the next
one I would go to let's just like in a
perfect world like every like all the
politicians we get paid by all these
[ __ ] crooked [ __ ] would somehow come
along with me then I would go to the
food [ __ ] industry and I would get
all of those [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of there
I'd find I go through their files and
find out what's really in our food and
simultaneously you'd go to the
pharmaceutical [ __ ] industry and find
out why the [ __ ] what they knew about
fentanyl and all of this because I've
had a bunch of people that I know
affected by it I've had friends die I've
had friends have children die it's just
been [ __ ] awful that's what I would
do and then I would the last thing I
would do what I would try to have some
sort of recycling program that works and
I don't know if that's what the [ __ ] I
would do and my vice president who would
it be who would it be oh I get Al
Franken
I'd have him as a vice president goats
all comedians in office I don't know I
try to just get people that actually
give a [ __ ] about people rather than
power and money like all of these other
[ __ ] [ __ ] like the bushes the
Obamas the Trump's the Clintons they're
just all bad people like I feel like the
last human being that was in office was
Jimmy Carter and you know let me look at
the guy what has he done since he's
retired other than build 4,000 houses
for the [ __ ] homeless oh these are
the [ __ ] [ __ ] what do they do
they go into the this speech tour and
they go out and they give speeches to
the biggest [ __ ] anti-american
goddamn corporate crooks but don't even
get me started on this [ __ ] I don't give
me [ __ ] started but everybody loves
[ __ ] Obama in his first two speeches
and were two of the biggest [ __ ]
predatory banks for [ __ ] 2008 I mean
it's like they don't even try to hide
but he's got a blue tie so I like him
it's like these [ __ ] morons that's
that can't even admit that Trump is a
[ __ ] dope
I get it you're Republican I get it
you're conservative I get it you want a
wall I get all of that if that's what
the [ __ ] you want and I respect it but
to [ __ ] take it to the point well you
can't say that this guy is a bit of a
[ __ ] you know I understand wind I
know all about the wind I mean the fact
that you're comfortable with that being
your leader I mean I don't know what the
[ __ ] say to you yeah that is as
annoying as people who prop up you know
the Obama's like these were these great
[ __ ] people rather than they were
your typical politicians that had their
faces in the [ __ ] pig trough just
like all of them just like all of them
no he wears a different colored tie he
wears the color tie that I like all
right let's get on let's not talk
politics here it just makes me annoyed
and then I start acting like I can solve
all the problems and that I know things
that I really don't so why don't we
avoid that although that could be part
of the entertainment all right all right
what's the next thing here
Jesus crisis is a long email
where the [ __ ] is this here wife's a
douchebag Jesus Christ noisy sex
Ukraine president okay noisy neighbors
having sex dear bill you are one of my
favorite car uh thank you my problem is
I can hear my neighbors having loud
obnoxious sex well it's the only way
it's obnoxious is if they're doing it to
annoy you they might be lost in the
throes of passion when was the last time
we want to [ __ ] face/off in this
[ __ ] game anyways loud obnoxious sex
at various times of the day I left a
note to them addressing the problem they
left a condescending response back with
their phone number in it why on earth
would I want to discuss their sex life
with them oh I would have called them
back in a second as you can see I'm in
quite the pickle here
that is my next move and what should i
do since seriously your biggest fan from
New Paltz New York oh dude this is easy
go get yourself a sound system all right
you got to do a little research to get a
scent get a sound system points up
speakers at the walls of your neighbor's
house all right and then what'd you do I
don't know if you can do a Google search
find the most obnoxious sex sounds from
a porno you watch you ever watch a porno
and somebody's like [ __ ] over the top
going like oh well I like you know and
it literally takes you out of it I would
record that on a loop and every time
they have sex you know I would play that
or you just make a tape of saying your
mom's vagina your mom's vagina your
mom's vagina is wet right now just
anything that will make that guy lose
his [ __ ] hard-on
have fun with it and then just say that
you're listening to a new song by Yoko
Ono and the Plastic Ono Band and
you know I think you'll get away with it
you got to have fun with it
record it you know have somebody
animated and all of that [ __ ] with you
and your [ __ ] yes send us send us
audio of it I have animators I'll pay
for it will [ __ ] it will [ __ ] make
a little cartoon about it and then do
that other [ __ ] just [ __ ] annoy him
back [ __ ] them and you also have their
oh and you could like put their phone up
now don't don't put their phone number
out there that there be a mean thing
that'd be to me taking it too far
all right wife's douchebag boss oh god
your wife has a douchebag boss so guess
what you have to hear about every night
at dinner what's up bill billy balls
snipped
hoping for advice why is scott a
douchebag boss just a little background
oh there's gonna be one of these no
punctuation x' no capital letters no
nothing just a little background my wife
is 45 I'm 38 wife's douchebag boss 28
this jackass thanks this jackass thinks
it's okay knowing she married Jesus
Christ dude what the [ __ ]
this isn't even a [ __ ] decent
sentence this jackass thinks it's okay
knowing she's married
JooJoo hit on her on a regular basis
little more backstory last year at her
Christmas party we were all drinking and
he decided it was okay to start hitting
on her in front of me she has a great
job for a retail company in a in a you
know mall makes 70 K a year so I didn't
want to screw it up but beating the ever
living crap out of him by by beating the
ever-loving crap out of him I decided to
let it slide the next day he apologized
and let it and I let it go figuring he
was just drunk well ever since he likes
to throw little comics about how she
smells nice his dress great the little
prick even likes to walk up behind her
and brush up against her act well what
the [ __ ] she can't just go to human
resources at this point you don't even
need evidence to
we got like [ __ ] evidence of this
[ __ ] just do that
he says cool I know my wife is not the
cheating type or she wouldn't be telling
me all this yesterday she came home sent
me upset and told me while she was in
the food court eating lunch he came up
behind her and told her he thinks she
would be great in bed
so here's my question before I drag this
a little shitstain down to the food
court and pull and pull a Goodfellas and
stick his [ __ ] head in the pizza oven
what should I do so I don't end up going
to jail
this advice would be great maybe
something from Nia it's Nia with an N
not meal with an M um no you can't do
that because then you're gonna go to
jail and he won't I don't understand why
she doesn't complain to somebody I mean
at this point all she would have to do
is go on Twitter say who the [ __ ] he was
and his career would be over
I think she can just threaten to do that
bill if you [ __ ] say one more goddamn
thing to me sexually or otherwise I will
go online and I will end your [ __ ]
career faster than you could say Harvey
Weinstein all right I actually think she
should just go to Human Resources I
don't know why she doesn't but you
should not go and beat the [ __ ] out of
this guy because you're gonna get caught
and you're gonna go to jail and then
that guy's gonna continue brought and
then then you think he's brushing up
against your wife ass then forget about
what about when you're locked up don't
do that I think you should you should go
to the proper channels here all right
advice my wife is disgusted by my
foreskin no brother
ten minutes to go ten minutes to go
please tell me we're not playing not to
lose I mean not to yeah to not lose
however expression goes no boy oh boy
you know they're gonna tie it up you
know they're gonna tie it up Jesus
Christ get it out of there oh my god
what are we doing
what are we doing on a billing
billingham fire-crotch love the podcast
and the advice you give first off I'm
personally fine with my old twig and
berries and haven't thought before skin
to be an issue but recently my wife of
two years has confessed that it makes
her gag I noticed her reluctance to the
one-eyed snake from the first time we
were together my first thought was she
didn't like them face-to-face or maybe
she was the size was the size of my
staff that she didn't like it's not
Larry very long but I am girthy and
that's fine with me I like to make the
joke I may not be able to touch the
bottom of the tuna can but I can touch
all the sides
long story short she's asked / demanded
that I get surgery to remove the excess
I don't know how to take that isn't love
beyond the physical thank you very much
bill I'll tell you this right now
there's no [ __ ] way you could ever
tell your wife to do something like that
I don't know what to tell you dude you
need to talk to a professional about
this one I can tell you this if someone
was gonna make me remove something from
my dick they would have to be in writing
a guaranteed number of blow jobs per
month here's the thing dude what if you
do that and then she still doesn't like
you dick you know there's been women
that married guys and then they get
divorced and then all of a sudden they
have a girlfriend you find out they're
gay anything can [ __ ] happen before
you start cutting [ __ ] off your dick
[ __ ] that that [ __ ] dick I wouldn't do
it I wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it and
I think it's really [ __ ] up that you
know that she married you if she was
look if she [ __ ] went on a date with
you and the first time he took out you a
little [ __ ] stumpy thick thing there
I she should have been honest with you
instead of [ __ ] grossed me out
and you guys could have left it at that
now she's two years into this [ __ ] this
is this is all her fault
for not [ __ ] communicating to you
that she thinks she'd dick is gross and
i'ma tell you right now dude do not
[ __ ] do that on any level [ __ ] you
this is my dick this is the dick I
showed up with and this is the dick I'm
leaving with okay and if she walks she
[ __ ] walks dude [ __ ] that I'm telling
you right now don't do it I got a bad
idea
remember platoon I got a bad feeling
about this one man I got a bad feeling
about this could you say to her you know
I you know you [ __ ] I don't your tits
grossed me out I don't know I don't know
man I wouldn't do it don't [ __ ] do it
that's that's my advice do not do it
keep your dick all original matching
numbers barn fine
Bruins almost Gord on that [ __ ]
breakaway goddamn it didn't almost score
had a breakaway but did not score
alright
advise friendís is in prison hey Billy
bullion I have a huge problem it needs
some a need your advice a friend of mine
whom I've known since the late 90s
recently went to prison he was a great
guy funny guy and we have the same sense
of humor we've stayed in touch for
almost two decades
sharing life's adventures family stories
joys and sorrows
so his met with sadness when he emailed
me a few months ago to explain that he
was experiencing serious legal trouble
they had a potential decade in prison
well what did he do
tax evasion embezzlement he said he
wasn't able to explain the details of
the case touch somebody I'm emailed him
back a week later to hope things worked
out whatever it was I said I didn't need
to know the details believe because I
believed he was a good character
eventually his wife responded and said
he's in prison she offered to put me in
contact with him all right well then he
didn't touch somebody if she's still
[ __ ] there that's my guess 8:36 to go
alright so until
today I kept in contact through the
prison email service and he's been
friendly and upbeat I didn't ask about
his situation because I thought that
whatever he did can't be that bad and he
won't want to talk about - he was going
to jail for ten years he too [ __ ] did
something guys don't talk about
emotional stuff after all I told him to
stay positive and just get through it
the best he can I wanted to show him
pictures of my new car but the prison
email can't do attachment so I asked my
partner about posting some photos she
googled his president saw it's a federal
prison she asked me what he's in for
I honestly said I don't know and she
started snooping oh boy then we found a
new story from town he pled guilty to
having thousands of kiddie porn pictures
there it is on his computer it's 100%
him no doubt not a case of mistaken
identity I feel so dumb for not googling
his name months ago so bill my question
is what do I do
the easy answer is to ignore him and cut
him out of my life that was my first
thought but I'm also human and he's
alone sitting in a prison cell realizing
his mistake is it possible to someone
still be a friend to this guy can
pedophiles change as far as I've seen no
not even remotely could you somehow
change what you're attracted to you're
attracted to what you're attracted to I
don't want to lose my friend because I
don't have many but he did unforgivable
things I feel let down but he supported
me as a friend for twenty years what do
I do well I think he just answered it
you you're a good friend and he's a good
friend but you just said what he did was
unforgivable so if it's unforgivable you
can't forgive him I don't know dude I'm
sorry going through it's pretty heavy
[ __ ] email as a father it's easy to
just cut them out of you like dude
you're a father you have kids yep you
got to get rid of this guy yeah you got
rid of many ways but imagine if you can
if one of your good friends did this I
can't forgive him but this moral ethical
decision is killing me thank you very
much for your time and go [ __ ] yourself
the last email is long and takes a turn
wasn't sure if you wanted to read it or
not but I threw it in there that's
hilarious
he sent that after he's after the email
text yeah oh if you think you owe it to
him as a friend to explain why I would
do that but yeah it's it's a wrap and
then I would just if you feel bad about
it I would just talk to my wife about it
oh if you feel you need to go talk to
somebody about it I would do that but
dude you got kids I mean you know those
people they're sick there's something
wrong with them and they haven't been
able to figure out how to fix them you
got to protect yourself and your family
so sometimes you know you got to choose
yourself and I think this is an easy one
you said it yourself what he did was
unforgivable all right that is the
podcast all right you guys have a great
couple of days here and I'll check in on
you on Thursday
those of you who want to listen to the
final five minutes and nine eight seven
seconds of this [ __ ] game you can
listen to the rest of this [ __ ]
podcast all right now we're in now we're
in overtime for the podcast the dog is
sleeping just screamed and I yelled the
F word Oh
Toronto is on the edge of their [ __ ]
seats here along gonna keep [ __ ] chant
and took his name like Keith that's
gonna rattle him he's been playing great
they scored in a deflection you know
can't blame a goalie for a deflection
and the second one was a nice goal I
could live with both of those especially
if they don't score another one
Bruins bringing the puck into the zone
go down half walk written off by some
come from Toronto
why didn't you [ __ ] yeah Jesus now
they gotta clear the zone oh my god
it was right there you know what happens
when you miss one of those the other
team [ __ ] scores Jesus Christ Taveras
is Matthew's out there too
they're on a different line thank Christ
you know at the end of the game that
balls gonna be out there the [ __ ]
goalie pulled why do I do this why don't
why do I give a [ __ ] you know whose
[ __ ] standing up get the [ __ ] out of
the way oh look at that sweet rebound
just sitting there waiting to be picked
up let me turn this up you can at least
hear it
3:09 to go 308 to go come on you know
you want a game seven right tell me you
want a game seven that's right - what
what Oh
action ah put down the ice here come the
Bruins
here come the Bruins there comes one
burro in any way for a stoppage of play
2:38 to go he just goes it's wonderful
isn't it now if your heart's in the
[ __ ] game
it's wonderful if you don't give a [ __ ]
look I'm a Calgary Flames fan and I'm
watching this I'm [ __ ] probably
having a good time because my team's
already out of it ah boy you know what I
didn't take into consideration here as
commercials you guys watched an Alexis
going around the racetrack like this is
a great car for the money huh I'd like
to think so was that shot nara's in
Australia they give me some militant
vegans running out in front of them cuz
the [ __ ] I'm so glad they moved on to
this guy this progressive commercials is
progressive what is this the guy with
the parrot I couldn't stand that one
with that asian chick going like what
the [ __ ] was that for white person did
that you'd be in trouble
ooh child
alright now I hit pause now they got a
black guy dancing with food at TGI
Fridays what is going on it's like
progressive and then it goes back
alright okay real estate
everybody's doing commercial stuff
there's more celebrities in commercials
than there are in superhero movies you
know alright back to the game
Djali McAvoy getting a skate on that how
the [ __ ] did Matthews missed that it's
probably in the air I know it wasn't his
fault
pasta knock you're a [ __ ] goal scorer
he's [ __ ] imitating crazy there
Anderson big-time saves you know what
else he has he has big-time rebounds and
I got to think your Bruins are gonna be
there to pick one up come on come on
Bruins 236 235 there you go keep it in
their end cycle it around a half wall
come on come on you [ __ ] oh Jesus
oh Jesus get it out of there the [ __ ]
are we doing two minutes to go through
the [ __ ] Toronto scores I filed two
minutes I'm shutting this [ __ ] thing
off uh game seven everybody oh my god
listen how [ __ ] quiet is in there why
the [ __ ] did they pull the goalie you're
only down by one goal I don't [ __ ]
get that with a minute to go maybe
[ __ ] Marshawn man he's the best
he's the best dick he's just [ __ ]
money he's just money on all the Bruins
to score for Toronto fans to get pissed
off it alright not a respect for the
Toronto Maple Leafs I'll watch the rest
of this Maple Leaf fans staying there
look at this very impressive what a
fanbase
I like those Montreal Canadiens fans
they would have all [ __ ] take it off
oh oh is that a tripping call what just
wide minute 22 to go the always
dangerous austin matthews all right out
of the zone I can never skate like that
least [ __ ] guys the defenseman are
amazing that [ __ ] [ __ ] sat down
didn't he down by two goals probably
left get it out of there get it out of
there please
[ __ ] not this guy not this guy you know
somebody's got this [ __ ] game that
gambling they're gonna [ __ ] pull the
goalie like this don't they care about
gamblers ah look at that just swallowed
it up no rebound
unlike Anderson oh we got a game seven
we got a game seven look at that [ __ ]
pass
unbelievable Tuukka Rask is always there
that chant his name now
Toronto fans chant is [ __ ] name now
not by any means same we're gonna win
this serious I'm just saying I'm just
glad it's gonna go seven here huge like
a Babcock what a great coach Cal Oh what
exactly is saying there's 31 [ __ ]
seconds left you know alright if you can
score on a faceoff in the zone and then
somehow after the faceoff you can score
at the red line can we do that then
maybe score again and we can get out of
here not going to overtime oh Jesus
alright here come your Boston Bruins
back out to center ice how many times
can they beat Toronto and a [ __ ]
playoff series when will Toronto get the
[ __ ] first round monkey off their
back I'm not gonna lie you I thought
they had us I thought they had us
especially the first 10 minutes of this
game and that's why I'm not a
professional athlete because I am a
quitter and your Boston Bruins do not
quit [ __ ] why is Austin Matthews always
on the side of the side of the [ __ ]
net with Indian toukas on the other side
just just sitting there with a stick on
the ice 16 points 7 seconds Laconia
there's got to be a game 7 alright you
don't listen to the final 16 point 7
seconds alright everybody thank you for
listening to the bonus time here on the
podcast congratulations to the Bruins
animate believes great playoff series
who knows who's going to win but game 7
is on Tuesday 14 seconds 13 12 11 10
knowing a salmon [ __ ] icing again
jesus [ __ ] christ
5.4 now I got to stick it out right I
said I was gonna stick it out you know
Nia you know me right when I say I'm
going to stick it out I stay
get out right didn't they used to be my
bathrobe it used to be it used to be my
bathrobe and then she took it look at
this guy
[ __ ] referee bet the over as far as
time goes how long this game would take
kicking people out of a face-off [ __ ]
5.4 seconds left for two two game there
you go that's the ball game
[ __ ] huge huge victory
congratulations to your Boston Bruins
all right I'll check in on you on
Thursday
you